you darvish who finished runner up to
trevor bauer for the national league cy
young last year in his final season in
chicago
he was their opening day starter and
struggled somewhere similar to kershaw
struggled on opening day
has been almost untouchable in two
starts since and mookie betts stepping
up to the plate to lead this one off for
the los angeles dodgers here we go game
two
and a swing and a miss good start for
you darvish
strikes out mookie bets and we're
underway one down
and here comes last night's hero for the
dodgers corey seeger
seeger will ground one back to darvish
underhanded
two down faces empty two outs and justin
turner stands in
not a strike three nice one two three
first for you darvish clayton kershaw
who tossed six shutout innings against
the nationals on sunday and his last two
starts now he's won them both and given
up just one run in 13 minutes
grisham leading it off curb is sitting
on the ground right side first baseman
muncie from the back they get grisham
down fernando tatis junior coming up
kershaw gets him swinging lift the
slider two up and two down
he really looks locked in just like
darvish this could be quite a duel
now it's machado curve is popped up
both pitchers sharp in the first inning
both pitchers go one two three off and
rolling in san diego
you darvish you needed only ten pitches
to work a one two three first
retire the first four to come to bat
here as chris taylor stands in
that a swing of the miss hugh darvish
picks up his third game of the night two
down
hugh's got it going on two outs here in
the second inning zach mckinstry
swinging a mess back-to-back case for
darvish
four and all he's retired the first six
dodgers
clayton kershaw set the padres down in
order in the first inning he got one
strikeout beat off man aboard for
jurickson profile
profile swings and misses good slider
from kershaw for his second k
tommy fan with myers at first and two
gone
he's [ __ ] him out kershaw with three k's
over a couple of scoreless innings
both guys locked in and it'd be victor
carratini to start this inning for the
padres her new catcher
and then a slider that carratini can't
lay off of kershaw's fourth kill
two outs and the base is empty and
gruesome the first man tonight to have a
second plate appearance
line to center field in for a base hit
first padres hit of the night
belongs to trent grisham keeps this
ending going for
tatis kershaw gets him again
and the dodgers continue to master
fernando tatis who is six for his last
47 against la it has been a brilliantly
pitched affair so far between darvish
and kershaw
base is empty two outs for profar he's
struck him
out so far i'm not sure what he's
complaining about
maybe he thinks he had a little
catcher's interference exactly
what happened and it is a reviewable
play it's kershaw
yelling out at profar he says that's
bolshoy
and that's a that's a play i saw it's a
russian ballet
and profar yelling at the dodgers and
walking from first base hershaw was
letting profar know
he thought he did that intentionally
they're gonna give him first base
the drama in this series continues from
last year cronenworth lifts it to center
field but no big deal for mookie butts
there are some sparks fly here in date
number two in the fourth inning of the
scoreless game
kershaw and darvish garbage was rolling
along as he takes a stroll in behind the
hill in the midst of a meeting with
himself
he had retired the first 14 dodgers in a
row then he hits mckinstry he gives up a
single to raley
and walks barnes kershaw comes up with
the bases loaded
having a discussion with tom hallian i'm
sure about that uh catcher's
interference call
darvish to kershaw three balls two
strikes
over the bases loaded walk and the
dodgers strike first
one nothing in the flat and now he's got
to deal with milky bats for the bases
still
chopped forward in the air to right
field myers wanders in
and takes care of out number three first
shaw no runs over four innings per shot
through the first four innings has five
strikeouts
swing and a miss strike three two gone
strikeout number six for clayton kershaw
to see two pitchers hitting their spots
although it was a different story in the
fifth for you darvish
and here's what comes to mind for me in
this inning donnie
uh the fifth inning rough sledding right
for darvish
very quick fifth for the pod race only
ten pitches thrown by kershaw
darvish is back out there which you
darvish are we going to see that's
strike three
wow garbage makes quick work in the
sixth inning
and that is strikeout number six for you
darvish
strike recall monsieur to take with him
the seventh strikeout for you darvish
a one two three six and garvish caps it
with a k
grisham walked to begin the inning still
second
tati struck out looking machado with a
base hit to left
they're at the corners with one out
first chance against kershaw
will myers comes to the plate 3-2 to
will myers
bouncing ball off of the mound to the
back goes taylor
he got
[Applause]
now jimmy nelson takes over finding
himself in his highest leverage spot yet
tying run in scoring position at second
base two outs for
victor caratini did he go
you bet he did it over after the lead
off walk
three consecutive k's for jimmy nelson
only two hits for the dodgers tonight
turner has struck out lined up
short struck out again how about some
insurance look at the 2-2
he goes back to the fastball golf to
left justin tunnel there it goes
[Applause]
the dodgers cash an important insurance
run
myers goes to third profile goes to
second
time running scoring position two gone
in the ninth inning
and up comes tommy fan butterflies
right knuckles edge of your seat
gonzalez is one
swagger right center field
[Applause]
a spectacular play by mookie betts
if he doesn't get it it's a tie game
instead betts saves the day
what a play by mookie bench to end the
game
full extension in the right center field
gap the dodgers two
the padres nothing they've taken the
first two
out of 19 and 20 21.